[Aplausos]
e aí ela que existe no planalto com
vocês e também o cara que beleza não
estou muito bem não estou um pouco disse
sabe quando vão ficar assim meio pode
estar saturado de tudo não tem assim não
sei explicar direito enquanto bate assim
uma depressão assim do nada eu quando
era uma novo assim na nazista na 7ª
série
eu era assim mais quero na minha estudar
mas da 8ª série pra frente e o eu
comecei a ficar assim mais extrovertido
a fazer piada além da primeira piada que
o filho professor de matemática falam
sobre estava aquele símbolo do infinito
professor perguntou símbolo do infinito
falou assim ninguém você sabe que
simboliza esse eu falei eu sei isso é 18
domingo cumprir isso evita a escola
assistir ao choque de matemática em todo
mundo a todo mundo não entende porque na
verdade minha intenção não era fazer
piada era fazer uma crítica àquela
altura chá aí quer desde que feita piada
e falou meu deus eu nasci para tempo que
a lista da minha filha não só que dali
pra frente eu me liguei que eu não
precisava ser calado não precisa ficar
quieto sim eu poderia dar minha opinião
e além de dar minha opinião as pessoas
poderiam achar graça da fifa está
falando gente você escutar alguns lado
lidar caixa do banheiro enchendo é
porque estava cagando em tirar tinta do
cairo têm que entender que nenhum
artista cargo quando a pessoa nasce os
médicos já olha vê assim não tem culpa
se a conquista diz assim olha daqui eu
venho tempo não manda para o gol e isso
aqui bonitinho também não tem como ana
paula lobo e esse aqui qual nasceu cinco
nessa situação por aqui pouco mais de
bola e manda pra novela da record há um
marketing também aqueles famoso que eles
nasce pobre e eles vão conquistando seu
sucesso ao longo do tempo na gente e se
sair eles nasce com cuba mas quanto mais
eles vão ficando famoso ao longo do
tempo ele vai perdendo chega o tempo a
gente está tão famoso que não tem mais
cura e não cabia mais
mais ou menos assim então eu comecei a
ficar mais engraçado só que nunca é que
quando a gente faz um morro a gente é
meio compreende porque as pessoas acham
que fica na frente de todo o tempo e
realmente eu sou uma pessoa que anda
feliz todo o tempo eu não sou essa
pessoa que liga a câmera e escreve um
texto que fala uma coisa que ela não
vive só pra aparecer se engraçado
spoiler meus vídeos expõe a meu ver
todos os meus vídeos coisa que aconteceu
na minha vida e eu achei engraçado eu
queria passar pra vocês pra você ir
daqui pode rir de mim eu gosto de você
ir lá mas ele não estava indo com ele
está rindo dele um pau no seu cunho
quero que você e eu não me importa o que
você e eu quero trazer felicidade para
você e às vezes button de pensão cara
não sei o que acontece quando fica sem
saco cheio e aí eu estava aqui me bateu
assim de pressão do seu que agora nos
falta energia e beleza hein galera
faltou energia para completar minha
depressão obrigado universo você está
fazendo direito e vai ficar com medo de
gravar porque tu me desculpe eu estava
pensando no banheiro é mas como agora tá
escuro não vou mais que eu sei que está
na chicala a galera sei lá eu tô com
vontade com a fazenda ao colocar de me
desligar da internet com 12 mês não tem
o tema seguinte porque eu fui morar
longe porque fui morar fora de casa
porque a vida é assim é você nasce
cresce e produz e morta ultimamente está
sendo assim vacinar cresce faz merda e
com um bercinho quartos mais uma vez que
é pago no carnaval se é produto da vila
e morre em acidente de carboidrato com
ódio tão grande de carro do meu teu que
o ser humano do ser humano dos seres
humanos aguento mais ouvir barulho de
carro aguento mais ouvir barulho de
avião e não me move as pessoas falam
tudo meu deus o que tá assim você está
me entendendo eu sei você então entendo
que eu estou falando coisa com coisa tá
bom eu vou resumir eu sou um cara que
faz vídeos engraçados eu sou humorista
eu sou um comediante e esse comediante
que passa tanta alegria para as pessoas
ficou triste do nada eu entendo que não
sei o que eu tô eu queria muito parecida
porque está consumindo
a ideia mas eu não posso e não posso
parar porque eu esse compromisso não é
comigo esse compromisso com você e eu
vou me esforçar mas eu queria pedir uma
coisa pra você e eu queria que você
comentasse aqui embaixo algum sinal uma
palavra de amizade alguma palavra de
incentivo não sei alguma coisa legal
assim que me senti melhor eu ficar
alegre no não sei se isso é só uma
depressão da madrugada porque agora são
agora são 3 50 da manhã é uma coisa
outra coisa também que sempre me motivou
e sempre continuar me motivou a fazer
via online que vocês vocês sabem é que
toda vez que o entre o canal no youtube
o vídeo no último vídeo tem 30 mil a r
40 mil lagoa gostavam fazer o tempo é
assim a galera do nosso esporte do mundo
você pode pensar a grama é gramas e
outra coisa poderá gente fazer uma
desnecessária drama porque eu juro que
eu não estarei aqui no meu tempo 3 50 da
manhã grava um vídeo pra falar o nome é
sério então dar um ok comentou um coisa
legal pra mim foi de agosto esse vídeo
não vou me suicidar telmo então valeu
obrigado por me escutar em meu trabalho
mesmo não vendo vocês é como se tivesse
um estádio lotado e você estivesse lá
100 mil pessoas lá dentro ouvindo que eu
não posso falar muito obrigado a você
que me dá força de longe e nós não
estamos vendo mais é porque ele está no
escuro valeu todo mundo é isso aí é
pouco comentando desings até triste
engraçado inteligente é porque eu não
quero chorar na band botei mas agora tá
escuro posso falar né
a sco também pode ser que a loira do
banheiro ele que até a linha 98 foi ele
quem está passando a mão na minha bunda
casa do bertoni peça topic os sexos não
vou cantar a música então finge nome que
o meu passa longe
a casa aceita que o meu povo não passa
longe de cada ser pai no seu esposo
médico de plantão e o papel de bosta que
ele faz aparelho não acho que o calor da
desgraça além disso imagine um chicote
do elenco do flamengo falou peixe do
coração do filho